than they did a year or a year ago also
in terms of just that identity that that
really kind of hardscrabble identity but
with that guy right there third walk of
the game rose again just the presence of
Everly
[Applause]
giman skis their trainer son of Mike
shim another block by Harold
I just love mantra is bringing the
energy that's quite a run a job there
[Applause]
the first time really in pre-season the
energy burst comes down and a great
block but my Tris that's all effort Lou
Williams finds Harold inside beautiful
girl in a jam
I would keep going back to that matchup
any time then not to pick on it but
anytime I get into a shooter they're
gonna shooter hooter
okay trace expanded his game way I'm
seven feet long and the coaching you
okay with montrezl harrell oil is the
foundation in this man's honors but he
all about this guy
Wow how much of a story do you want
Heritage Day coming up January 6th at
Staples Center
the Clippers have really drive on being
aggressive to attack the basket Terrell
does the same as montrezl harrell
finishes there's no answer and swanigan
from purdue for montrezl harrell uses
his speed the Broadway incorrect Chicago
is fun Chicago's very close to Indiana
our home
tony snell that spells trouble for the
defense it down to six three-point
possession for the caboose what else is
he gonna do is from Thompson but the
rest of guys got to get the defensive
board that closed up by Harold we're in
the boxes to buy heroin ahead
per lead than cut in half two minutes to
go in the third
to lock down what the hell that was some
pants
plenty of traffic there if you're the
Clippers right now
warriors want to pit want to speed up
the pace of this game right now
ring blocked from behind by Harold
challenged by Harold he leaks out come
to life I'm pretty sure he just baptized
him to play one more time
defense with his second half that
Dubai's hair is fine trip trees and look
at him baptized on their bike Gallinari
box it out Markieff Morris the LOB the
jam
Harrell from gilja's Alexander flippers
by 5 again think the sound would seem so
far pages reduces you see basket plus
one that's what they do out the
perimeter the track great move that was
right there good feed by Lou Williams
with Scott Williams Harrell going the
Holden's going it's a smart way of a
flipper on the court
smart play toes of one of the plays from
Dennis Smith junior were plus one it's
what res Harrell to improve player of
the year he's running for being an
all-star this year the waves when he's
running for office I guess it was a
negative factor of the previous video
almost invisible nice little fax door
cuts and passed to Merrill I for that is
the highest percentage shot Avery
Bradley the boxer Harold
finds a cutting Hera's another dumb
shooting now if you move the basketball
for once out of the floor you can get
quality jump shot step back home on
trans head throws down the 3-ball energy
in that time right there it's a little
too much on the chumbucket or
[Applause]
[Music]
Ralph he's only playing 25 minutes a
game it's not like he's out there for 37
minutes block by Harold what else is he
gonna do what's the recovery by Harold
follows the play doesn't give up on it
goes up early anticipating the shot
time's it perfectly lined up has had the
biggest impact into the corner wide open
three ball by gallo it goes deep in the
hole and bounds out and Tuckers get it
back and put it down it's still in the
game you don't think pop is trying to
send a message knocked away by hara
works hard to a basket ladder you would
say gliding to a bucket here to see
montrezl harrell for a sick guy six foot
eight that can play power forward and
center decent handled nice little step
over with the jammers but no silly event
among all of his awards and all of his
accomplishments he was also named
teammate of the year
years ago the follow by Beverly who is
everywhere the mansard points by Phoenix
[Music]
Herald family feel free to beat the
buzzer bingo great recognition there Bob
mantras hero 45% now from saving grace
for the Clippers you had a chance it's
more hired as a coach in Charlotte some
years ago by the time the season began
you said no no I want to watch my kids
play basketball that's what I am that's
what's frustrating
you got Avery Bradley
we have three guys around him into the
pics where he finally lost him there
Ralph me the truth was another
underachiever really right now is it
eight point eight points that's enough
for twenty four million dollars each
element standpoint from from Stanley you
got to be hungry every single topped to
be a better player Carol after here's
Travis what that means dancin on the
land is just look at the versatility of
tracing you know just twenty years of it
Oh doctor ball beautifully to Harold
Purdue timeout the joy
[Music]
the bar pen so I always talk about the
three draft guys that I have Ralph Paton
was wrong the whole easy game we do it
that way
this bounty if you dare
[Applause]
rebounds and the triple-double with this
assist with an ice blade to montrezl
Harrel mangly at 28% three-point
shooting that's why nobody the darting
in there then behind the powders pearl
listed optimistically at 6 feet Beverly
tock clock to five breathing left-handed
hook very nicely done
normally goes to the right hand that
time he got it for the left and Bradley
to the tippy here's Bradley with it the
floater
oh what a dutiful lob it goes to Harold
who's knows her down but this is a great
basketball IQ play spider gravity 753
stop loader torva get an easy one a nice
speed Harold the lead is 25
that's about as more thing can you live
with
blocked from behind by Harold Heatran
and continue to follow the play to get
another block shop for steam the 7% as a
team
make sure to bunch of them Oh Monster
Jam thrown down by montrezl Harrel oh
you spring down a lane and you know the
man mr. Lewin's is going to find his
running mate they had the biggest
comeback in franchise regular season
history coming from 25 down in Detroit
they're trying to top it here tonight
[Applause]
beautifully done
that gets pleated by three he he just
close to the basket and there's just
damage control but that orange who his
brother might have felt that one be good
around the room I think he's one of the
more underrated players on the Nuggets
funny time to get off a John Merrill
with five seconds to go
[Applause]
all goes to get the rebound dodge its
digit is off the chart
locked inside by Harold and wouldn't be
bad for a 29 year old right here'll slam
dunk and a foul 10 from on trail turns
out like if he is it a ceiling and he
stays this way
a monster throw down by montrezl harrell
have a field day any name on man
competition the COS got a bet on here we
go throw it down
and remember last year and he was he was
playing into the Year Garrett temple
into the fifties as well the Williams
inside
nor so many ways was it the last time
out we're shooting sixth and 4.8 there -
their high game for the year's 59.5
another basket another bound me Ralph in
the first quarter when I said if the
Clippers get 125 tonight they'll be
doing something I didn't laugh I tended
to chuckle three ball by hair money
missing draft picks
Chandler nice feed inside for two plus
one
can become more and more valuable to
this club moving closer and closer to
the playoffs he's a veteran player Ralph
that that knows how to play we buy a
dozen
we'll look past the first round
Restylane I think I'm not gonna lose
this game will go back to her face stock
was def curry light by nineteen Gallo
The Herald for two
[Music]
sure did no just Alexander
[Applause]
and if you towel into your singer che
with the setup
montrezl her and that wasn't a perfect
play tough fault got a high bounce peril
Oh got to the goal somehow found Harold
go up and score what I shot my montrezl
Harrel thank you Montreux that's kind of
a dangerous game to play
it is indeed Harold head down charge the
basket banked it in the basket companies
following section a lesson for three
[Applause]
season about montrezl he was 2 for 15
coming in go back two feet set knock it
down now the crowds into it if they can
keep it going to start the second half
but Trez doing it all we dunk it on the
next possession what happened yesterday
after the ankle sprain
at the hip call done in a few years but
he also knows he's the primary option
out there with all these young Gigli
guts jobs like that or what gets this
building going though deflect it away
and recover it and jam this by Harold or
a clipper game I think it was with Mike
Green and myself she was excellent
- Michael Green underneath gets the
bucket and a foul on Sefolosha
this run able to fly the rein in Game
one as here gave to a hello goes right
at Bogut it was looking to the block
earlier tonight the Rockets took the
series against Utah
if the beautiful bounce pass is held up
here if a final minute and a half but it
is held up because two urgency now now
they're playing Warriors ball two
Warriors passion
[Applause]
rejected you're supposed to get dumped
going on his play my trance Harold
coming over getting the block the tough
block was changed what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content